hemos visto que muchos sustituyen tes
voluminosos prefieren estar en posición
ecuatorial en lugar de estar en una
posición axial en nuestras con
formaciones silla y a veces necesitamos
realmente calcular cuál es la diferencia
de energía con números especialmente
para moléculas complicadas
paul y sustituidas como estos ejemplos
de ciclohexano que vamos a trabajar y
que de hecho hemos estado trabajando un
poco así que aquí tengo una una tabla en
donde podemos mostrar una estimación de
la diferencia de la energía entre las
posiciones axiales y ecuatoriales así
que por ejemplo un grupo de cloro o aquí
sí sí tenemos por ejemplo por ejemplo un
cloro que se une a la molécula vamos a
tener una diferencia en la energía de
dos muy bien 2.0 ahora bien si tenemos
un grupo o h ok si tenemos si tenemos un
grupo h la diferencia es de 4.2 si
tenemos un grupo metilo la diferencia la
diferencia es de 7.6 un grupo estilo
tendríamos una diferencia de 8 mientras
que la diferencia con un grupo iso
propio sería de 9.2 y el más voluminoso
de todos los que tenemos en esta tabla
sería el grupo textil cuya diferencia es
de 22.8 así que el termo til prefiere
mucho más la posición ecuatorial por
22.8 kilo jules por mol dado que es el
más digamos el conjunto más abultado de
todos los que tenemos aquí verdad así
que vamos a ver un ejemplo de un ciclo
hexano 3 sustituido y vamos a ver si
podemos ver cuál de las conformaciones
si ya es la más estable así que vamos a
empezar por dibujar nuestra estructura
de puntos vamos
tener aquí nuestro ciclohexano
ok más o menos algo así
muy bien entonces aquí está un poco
chueco y raro nuestro ciclohexano pero
vamos a poner en este ciclo hexano tres
grupos sustituye entes verdad entonces
esto que vamos a dibujar es el cloruro
de neón ventiló y eso es porque aquí
tenemos
digamos un grupo hizo propio un grupo
hizo propio el pero que además está
apuntando digamos hacia nosotros eso va
a estar en nuestro primer carbono en el
segundo carbono vamos a tener un grupo o
vamos a tener un cloro que está saltando
justamente hacia nosotros muy bien
es un grupo de cloro y vamos a tener
hasta el cuarto carbono vamos a tener un
grupo metilo que va en dirección
contraria a nosotros muy bien entonces
este es el cloruro de neón ventiló y
vamos a dibujar las conformaciones
sillas para poder determinar cuál es la
conformación más estable muy bien
entonces recuerden que hay que hacer
esto con mucha calma porque en principio
puede ser complicado dibujar esto verdad
hay más o menos entonces tenemos
nuestras posiciones axiales arriba abajo
arriba abajo
arriba y abajo y luego si nos vamos con
las ecuatoriales sería abajo arriba
bah
y hacia arriba muy bien entonces esa es
una conformación silla y podemos ir a la
otra conformación silla muy bien aquí
empezamos más o menos de esta forma
menos
más o menos ahí tenemos como como el
relámpago que habíamos dicho verdad y
vamos hacia arriba hacia abajo en las
posiciones axiales arriba abajo arriba
y abajo muy bien y luego vamos en las
ecuatoriales hacia abajo hacia arriba
hacia abajo hacia arriba hacia abajo
y hacia arriba muy bien ahí están las
dos con formaciones sillas y ahora en
nuestro primer carbono tenemos nuestro
grupo y soprole entonces aquí está el
primer carbono y el grupo iso propio va
hacia arriba entonces tenemos algo así
muy bien ahí está nuestro grupo y su
propio en el segundo carbono tenemos
este cloro que está saliendo en hacia
arriba verdad entonces en el segundo
debemos poner el cloro que sale en
dirección digamos hacia arriba entonces
podemos ver que en el primer carbono el
grupo hizo propia y tenía una posición
axial mientras que en el segundo el
cloro tiene una posición ecuatorial muy
bien y nos vamos hasta el cuarto carbono
el cuarto carbono corresponde a este de
aquí que dice que el grupo metilo va
hacia abajo en este caso pues tendría
que ir en dirección o más bien en una
posición axial
entonces ahora vamos a ver qué ocurre
con la otra conformación sigue entonces
nuestro primer carbono ahora se
encuentra aquí verdad este sería el
primer carbono y al hacer la inversión
del anillo lo que vamos a tener es que
este grupo hizo propio y también va a
apuntar hacia arriba pero en vez de
estar en posición axial ahora se
encuentra en posición ecuatorial muy
bien y si te recomiendo que a lo mejor
revises un poco sobre el modelo en los
vídeos anteriores para ver cómo es esta
inversión del anillo en el segundo caso
en el más bien en el caso del segundo
carbono tenemos que el cloro estaba
apuntando hacia arriba en una dirección
ecuatorial entonces en el segundo a un
estar apuntando hacia arriba pero
cambiará su posición a una posición
axial mientras que en el cuarto carbono
teníamos una posición axial hacia abajo
entonces aquí en el cuarto carbono vamos
a tener una posición hacia abajo pero
ahora será ecuatorial entonces ahí
tenemos las dos con formaciones silla
para
el cloruro de metilo ahora vamos a
comparar vamos a utilizar la tabla que
teníamos anteriormente
porque realmente no es obvio
inmediatamente cuál de estas dos con
formaciones es la más estable
necesitamos checar nuestra tabla aquí
así que si empezamos con el grupo hizo
propio el que sería este de aquí tenemos
una diferencia de 9.2 y sabemos que el
grupo bueno cualquier grupo
cualquier grupo sustituyen te prefiere
estar en posición ecuatorial en este
caso tendríamos que agregar 9.2 kilo
jules dado que éste se encuentra en
posición axial y sabemos que mientras
que va a ser más estable mientras más
baja sea la cantidad de energía entonces
en este caso agregamos 9.2 que pasa con
el cloro con el cloro agregamos un 2
vamos a agregar un 2 donde se encuentra
en posición axial que sería en el caso
de la derecha verdad 2 y finalmente
vamos a agregar 7 puntos 6 debido al
grupo metilo en el caso en el que se
encuentra en posición axial que sería el
caso de la izquierda entonces creo que
es bastante claro y obvio que el caso de
la izquierda tiene una mayor cantidad de
energía potencial así que eso lo hace
menos estable y en ese caso la más
estable sería nuestra conformación de la
derecha muy bien así que estamos
pensando que para el cloruro de nheo
ventiló la mayor parte del tiempo la
molécula va a estar en la conformación
de la derecha en donde el cloro se
encuentra en posición axial y eso es muy
importante para reacciones químicas que
vamos a hablar ya sea en unos minutos o
quizás en el próximo vídeo así que vamos
a comparar ahora el cloruro de nheo
ventiló con el cloruro de metilo ok son
muy similares en términos de su
estructura de puntos de hecho aún saber
lo vamos a irlo dibujando tenemos
nuevamente nuestro ciclohexano
ciclo y sano
ahí lo tienen y vamos a tener también
aquí en nuestro primer carbono un grupo
iso propio y piso propio perón ok allí
está el grupo hizo pro pilot en el
segundo vamos a tener también un cloro
pero en vez de que esté apuntando hacia
nosotros como en el caso anterior va a
estar apuntando en dirección contraria y
finalmente en el cuarto carbono también
vamos a tener nuestro grupo metilo muy
bien entonces realmente la gran
diferencia entre el caso anterior y éste
es que el cloro en vez de apuntar hacia
nosotros apunta en dirección contraria
ahora vamos a dibujar nuestras con
formaciones silla
otra vez esta estructura
y ahí está
más o menos y empezamos verdad que con
la posición axial arriba abajo arriba
abajo arriba y abajo ahora vamos con las
ecuatoriales va hacia abajo hacia arriba
hacia abajo hacia arriba hacia abajo y
hacia arriba muy bien ahí tenemos
nuestra primera conformación silla
vamos con la segunda que sería empezar
digamos en este en este sentido
si quizás lo hice muy grande verdad
un poco aquí
aunque digo esto a lo mejor son
cuestiones de estética lo importante es
que queden claros los conceptos pero
aquí tenemos ya nuestra conformación
bueno nuestro sitio hexano y ahora
ponemos hacia arriba abajo arriba abajo
arriba y abajo y ahora con los
ecuatoriales va hacia abajo hacia arriba
hacia abajo hacia arriba hacia abajo y
finalmente hacia arriba verdad entonces
en nuestro primer carbono nuevamente
tendremos un grupo hizo propio y lo que
apunta hacia arriba en este caso es una
es una posición
axial verdad en el segundo segundo
carbono tendremos un cloro que apunta
ahora hacia abajo que en este caso pues
tendría que ser una posición axial
también y en el cuarto carbono tendremos
un
en este cuarto carbono tendremos un
grupo metilo que apunta hacia abajo y
que nuevamente es en una posición axial
en el caso de la derecha que tendríamos
tendríamos aquí nuestro primer carbono y
sigue apuntando hacia arriba el
isopropílico pero ahora está en posición
ecuatorial entonces aquí está nuestro
grupo hizo propio el cloro ahora se
encuentra en posición ecuatorial verdad
este es nuestro cloro en posición
ecuatorial hacia abajo y en el cuarto
carbono que sería justamente este si
estaba apuntando hacia abajo en posición
axial ahora se encuentra hacia abajo
pero en posición ecuatorial entonces
vamos a ver que realmente éste todavía
es un caso mucho más sencillo porque en
este caso de la izquierda tenemos que
los tres sustituye entes están en
posición axial y sabemos que los
sustituye entes prefieren estar en
posición ecuatorial
es decir si nos fijamos en la tabla que
pusimos al inicio el cloro agrega 2 kilo
jules por mol
el grupo metilo agrega 7 puntos 6 kilos
por mol y el grupo hizo propio 9.2 kilo
jules por mol entonces en el caso de la
izquierda tendremos una una diferencia
digamos a favor de 9.2 más dos verdades
es por el cloro y 7.6 más por el grupo
metilo entonces creo que es mucho más
obvio que el grupo de la izquierda tiene
una mayor energía potencial o un
impedimento estético mucho mayor y eso
hace que el caso de la derecha sea más
estable verdad el caso o la conformación
de la derecha va a ser mucho más estable
porque todos los grupos son ecuatorial
es verdad el cloruro de metilo va a
gastar más tiempo digamos en esta
conformación que si tuviera el cloro
digamos en posición axial verdad en este
caso de la derecha tiene una posición
ecuatorial y en una reacción que vamos a
cubrir en vídeos posteriores el átomo de
cloro tiene un 1
tiene que estar en posición axial para
poder reaccionar para que la reacción
ocurra y eso es porque porque el cloruro
de metilo gasta más más tiempo en esta
conformación y no va a reaccionar tan
rápido por ese mecanismo debido a que la
mayor parte del tiempo el cloro se
encuentra en una posición ecuatorial
sólo una pequeña porción digamos se
gasta digamos en él
en el cloro axial verdad y eso es en
contraste con el ejemplo anterior en el
cne o en el cloruro de neo mentí la
verdad en este caso la conformación más
estable es justamente cuando el cloro se
encuentra en una posición axial así que
para esa reacción
dado que el cloruro de nheo mentí lo
gasta más tiempo digamos con el cloro en
su posición
axial de hecho va a ser más fácil para
que este mecanismo se lleve a cabo y si
y si este mecanismo se lleva a cabo la
reacción va a proceder con una mayor
velocidad para él el cloruro de nheo
mentí lo que si lo comparamos por
ejemplo con el cloruro de metilo y esto
es más o menos por un factor de 200 así
que esta es una de las cosas importantes
por las cuales hay que entender las
conformaciones de las moléculas